le décor une jungle luxuriante
les héros des gorilles les premières
planches colorées sont presque prêtes
le scénario est en phase d'être achevée
il ya quelques semaines du bouclage de
la mise en page et je relis le scénario
et je vérifie que les cases les bus
longuet n'était placé au niveau des
planches la bande dessinée est inspiré
d'une histoire vraie celle de deux
gorille femelle kuimba et mayumbe nés au
zoo parc de beauval et relâché en
afrique en 2010 neuf ans
celui qui ouvre la cage ce jour-là n'est
autre que le directeur du parc
[Musique]
parlons un peu des héros de la bbc la
nouvelle mayombe vraisemblablement
gestantes après des signes de chaleur
pouvoir raconter à travers la bande
dessinée cette histoire superbe puis
ensuite en plus on apprend que mayombe
et gestantes donc quelque part
l'aventuré se poursuit bien au delà de
la bd avec cette bd c'est l'une des
missions du parc qui est mise en avant
celle de la sauvegarde des espèces c'est
vraiment du concret c'est une histoire
vraie que l'on raconte une histoire est
une histoire qui est un papus la
conservation de la biodiversité dans ce
livre d'autres défenseurs de la
biodiversité sont mises en lumière
j'aimerais aussi rendre hommage quelque
part et ce sont les personnages aussi
principaux de cet album à tous ces
gardes à ses rangers qui au risque de
leurs vies au péril de leur vie
essaye de maintenir de sauver les
populations les espèces sauvages
menacées notamment les gorilles les
gardes lutte ainsi contre la
déforestation ou le braconnage pour
permettre au gorille de retrouver en
toute sérénité la terre de leurs
ancêtres
voilà